we're getting a closer walk inside the
mansions off Chloe and her sister
Courtney their designer who decked out
some I mean sick clauses that pretty
much any woman would die for it gives us
the details it used to be two bedroom
suites and it's been totally not into
this astronomical extraordinary closet
Bravo's million dollar decorators and
author
martyn lawrence-bullard only showed ET
how he made each space distinct to suit
each Kardashian Khloe's house is much
more about fantasy and comfort it's a
single girls house light and bright and
sexy meanwhile mom to three Kourtney
keeps it more relaxed and modern with
spaces for her kids to lounge
comfortably but mom gets her me-time
inside her art filled office and outside
on this luxurious pool Terrace it's so
pretty out here Khloe and Courtney's
homes featured in Architectural Digest
out February the 9th or around the
corner from each other in a private
Calabasas California enclave Courtney
purchased her 11,500 square foot Tuscan
style home from former NFL star Keyshawn
Johnson about a month later khloe bought
this 10,000 square-foot Mediterranean
Revival house from Justin Bieber but
they've made each space their own it's
all about following your heart
you